dazu Fragen jetzt an den
Bundesgesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach schönen guten Morgen guten
Morgen Frau Lauterbach zentrales ihre
Element ihrer krankenhausreform ist ja
sie wollen jede vierte stationäre
Behandlung ambulant durchführen lassen
also ebenfalls im Krankenhaus dadurch
spart man sich dann vielleicht die
Übernachtung und Übernachtungskosten
sparen sich die Kassen was soll das den
Pflegenden bringen die Nachtdienste
fallen weg also wenn diese Leistungen so
wie im Ausland auch über tagebracht
werden und dann gehen die Patienten über
Nacht nach Hause müssen nicht dazu näher
versorgt werden wie das in vielen
europäischen Ländern passiert mit
mindestens genauso guten meistens
besseren erbarnungsergebnissen dann
fallen diese schweren Schichtdienste für
viele Pflegekräfte Weg wir haben ja
nicht zu wenige Pflegekräfte gemessen an
der Bevölkerung sondern wir setzen sie
sehr wenig effizient ein wir behandeln
sehr viel stationär was ambulant gemacht
werden könnte das geht zu Lasten der
pflegekr wir haben gerade natürlich
gehört dass es freie Betten gibt und die
sind nicht deshalb frei weil es keine
Patienten auch Patientin gibt sondern
weil die Pflegekräfte selber erkrankt
sind erschöpft sind oder aber auch
einfach nicht mehr können und nicht mehr
wollen und jetzt muss man ja sagen die
Situation war ja schon vor Corona lange
angespannt und das liegt sicherlich auch
an der präventisierung der Krankenhäuser
also im Grunde sind das kleine
Wirtschaftsunternehmen geworden die am
Profit am Profit orientiert sind was
bedeutet das weitere Kliniken schließen
und Kräfte bündeln wir machen eine große
Reform jetzt da geht es um die
Überwindung dieses Systems der
Fallpauschalen die Fallpauschalen haben
die Kliniken ja komplett durch
ökonomisiert man bekommt einen Betrag
pro Fall und wenn ich den billig
erbringe mache ich gewinnen habe ich
hohe Kosten mache ich Verlust haben sie
damals mitgetragen ja das war damals
aber nicht so eingeführt jetzt ist es
wirklich nach vorne gegangen damals war
das Profit denken vor 20 Jahren noch
nicht so ausgeprägt wie heute egal auf
jeden Fall wollen wir das Überwinden da
spielen dann Vorhaltekosten größere
Rolle die Unikliniken werden etwas
besser also abgesichert finanziert das
ganze System wird etwas weniger
ökonomisch dann betrieben die
Pflegekräfte werden stark entlastet eine
große Reform ich glaube ich übertreibe
nicht wenn ich sage dass wir zumindest
versuchen mit dem mit der
Expertenkommission Krankenhaus die
größte krankenausreform der letzten 20
Jahre zu machen weil das
wahlpauschalensystem ist ja 20 Jahre
nicht reformiert worden Entlastung
sollen kommen finanzielle Entlastung
dazu treffen sie sich heute mit dem
Finanzminister Christian Lindner sie
haben schon gesagt sie werden sich vor
dem Gespräch dazu auch nicht äußern wie
viel der Bund dann übernehmen wird
kommen wir mal zu einer anderen Zahl 95%
der Bevölkerung besitzen laut einer
Studie Antikörper gegen das Coronavirus
Zitat demnach ist ein Großteil der
Menschen in Deutschland moderat bis gut
gegen schwere Verläufe geschützt das
sagt die Bundesforschungsministerin die
diese Studienauftrag gegeben hat warum
lockert Deutschland nicht wie andere
Länder naja wir sehen ja das trotz
dieser Antikörper sehr sehr viele
Menschen erkranken übrigens auch schwer
erkranken weil diese Antikörper sagen ja
nicht irgendetwas darüber aus ob das
noch Antikörper sind gegen die neuen
Varianten wie hoch der twitter ist ob
der dreistelliges vierstellig somit
wissen wir viele von denjenigen die zum
Beispiel nur die Grundimmunisierung
haben zwei Impfungen und das liegt lange
zurück erkranken ihr es auch sehr schwer
wenn sie älter sind und daher ist der
eigentliche antitet nicht will viel wert
man muss wissen um welche Varianten geht
es ist das durch Impfungen ist das durch
Erkrankungen wie hoch ist der Täter wir
sehen
dass ich da unterbrechen weil sie
erwecken natürlich da den Eindruck sie
zählen nur eine Studie
oder sagen Sie die ist korrekt oder die
hilft uns wenn Sie so in ihren narrativ
passt nein also zunächst einmal ich
arbeite ja zusammen mit dem Expertenrat
den wir also aufgebaut haben und mit dem
Expertenrat bin ich im engen Austausch
und der Expertenrat vertritt nicht die
Position dass man jetzt sagt okay wir
sehen 95 Prozent haben Antikörper wir
brauchen nichts mehr zu tun das wird
dort nicht vorgetragen somit bin ich da
ich sag mal im Konsens der Experten die
uns auch beraten wir haben eingangs die
Zahlen gerade genannt jeder zehnte geht
in Deutschland arbeiten trotz einer
Infektion jetzt gibt es ja hier die
Forderung auch zurück zur Normalität
deutschland solle somit Corona umgehen
wie mit einer Grippe wenn man krank ist
bleibt man im Bett und wenn man keine
Symptome hat kann man einfach arbeiten
gehen was sagen sie dazu ja dann würden
sie ja sehr stark steigen die Fallzahlen
wir haben ja jetzt schon hohe
fahrtzahlen das wird auch im späten
Herbst im Winter wird das ein großes
Problem sein und das geht alles zu
lastende Pflegekräfte aber auch zu
Lasten dere die schwererkrankungen und
wir verlieren derzeit weit über 100
Mädchen an Corona jeden Tag mit oder an
Corona die Menschen sterben das möchte
ich nicht noch anheizen von daher bitte
ich um Verständnis der Vorschlag
überzeugt nicht und deswegen sind sie
auch weiter für die Maske jetzt gibt es
Forderungen von Krankenhäusern dass sie
sagen in den Krankenhäusern wollen wir
wieder eine maskenpflicht andere sagen
sogar in allen Innenräumen und dann gibt
es Leute die sagen weg mit der Maske
mehr Eigenverantwortung in den
Krankenhäusern gibt es ja die
maskenpflicht da ist ja die ffp2-maske
also vorgegeben wir werden in die
Diskussion in einem kommen brauchen wir
die maskenpflicht wieder in den
Innenräumen das wird noch ein paar
Wochen dauern ich hoffe dass die Länder
sich verantwortlich zeigen weil wenn man
es nicht tut das geht wie gesagt zu
lassen der Pflege das geht zu lassen der
Krankenhausversorgung wenn die Kliniken
voll sind dann fahren die Notdienste aus
ich glaube dass es im Innenraum im
Winter spätestens notwendig sein wird
dass wir Masken tragen oder uns testen
lassen das ist ja die Alternative und
dass wir dann einfach besser durch diese
Zeit kommen ich glaube dass diese
Einschränkung besser ist als dass wir
wirklich in dieses Risiko hineingehen
viele Kranke viele Tote und Überlastung
der Krankenhäuser sagt der
Bundesgesundheitsminister Klarheit wäre
gut in Zügen muss man sie tragen beim
Fliegen nicht das ist immer noch ein
Durcheinander aber es ist eben auch zum
Großteil der Ländersache vielen Dank
Herr Bundesgesundheitsminister ich danke
Ihnen